justin rose has
a u.s open title and an olympic gold
medal in his back catalogue but the
masters has
so far eluded him a seven under par
opening round of 65
has put the englishman four shots clear
at the top of the leaderboard
[Applause]
a finish that had looked unlikely for
the 40 year old when he was two over
after seven holes you can't win the golf
tournament today even with the 65
you can't win it today um you can only
probably lose it today
obviously and uh i was very aware being
couple over through seven that
things were you know didn't hit the
panic button yet but i kind of i reset
just prior to that and i just thought if
i can get myself back around even par
you know that would be a good day's work
jordan spieth arrived in augusta having
just won the texas open
a triple bogey on the ninth wasn't in
his masters plan
but the 2015 champion was able to regain
his composure
and he finished on one under par
defending champion and world number one
dustin johnson is too over
no son of a gun
well bryce and deshambo's stated aim of
overpowering the course didn't quite
work out
he finished up on four over
four-time major champion rory mcelroy
hit the same score
and his own father's leg with this
wayward shot
perfect shot it was dead straight um but
i think he was okay i don't think he uh
he didn't limp away he walked away
pretty swiftly so that was all right
england's tommy fleetwood wasn't having
a great day until this happened on the
16th
a hole in one moving him up to two over
par
andy richardson al jazeera